if the Democrats are are doing as
exactly as you described they are saying
the rule of law doesn't matter the
Constitution doesn't matter we don't we
don't care about what your witness says
I mean look in in Georgia they released
the indictment on Trump before the grand
jury even voted there but they clearly
have fabricated this for political
purposes you but this is the thing that
I find fascinating right they post it
and then they lie about it right they
literally were like oh that was a you
know uh fictitious fictitious then it
comes out again and then they get caught
lying again about what it was this is
what blows my mind no one cared
like the idea I don't think that's true
no no no we did okay but the idea that
no major Network said they just got
caught in a lie this is what that and I
know that let me let me try this France
didn't care right
the people the people of France didn't
care at all that this information came
out right that's how you need to start
viewing the Democrats